It's 4 a.m. and the big test is in eight hours followed by a piano recital.
You've been studying and playing for days,...
...but you still don't feel ready for either.
So, what can you do?
Well, you can drink another cup of coffee...
...and spend the next few hours cramming and practicing.
But believe it or not, you might be better off closing the books,...
...putting away the music, and going to sleep.
Sleep occupies nearly a third of our lives,...
...but many of us give surprisingly little attention and care to it.
This neglect is often the result of a major misunderstanding.
Sleep isn't lost time or just a way to rest when all our important work is done.
Instead, it's a critical function,...
...during which your body balances and regulates its vital systems,...
...affecting respiration and regulating everything...
...from circulation to growth and immune response.
That's great, but you can worry about all those things after this test, right?
Well, not so fast.
It turns out that sleep is also crucial for your brain,...
...with a fifth of your body's circulatory blood being channeled to it as you drift off.
And what goes on in your brain while you sleep...
...is an intensely active period of restructuring that's crucial for how our memory works.